how do you deal with people who have
been brainwashed
into believing that we are the enemy and
scientology is fundamentally um
silly in my view and that and although
it has a ton of money it doesn't have
many adherents
however i think it's important to study
it
and to understand it because
if we can work out how to unbrainwash
members of the church of scientology we
might be able to work out how to
unbrainwash
people who are adherents of islamic
states
or who believe that north korea
is the one people in the north korean
military believe that north korea is
wonderful
how do we unlock that brainwashing
is important and and that's why
psychologically it's interesting now the
guy who's done
a ton of thinking about this is a
wonderful
american military psychiatrist
originally called professor robert
lifton
who wrote the first book about
brainwashing
um using that term thought reform or
brainwashing
and he'd been the military psychiatrist
called in
to treat american gis who'd been
brainwashed by the chinese communists
the maoists
in um at the end of the um korean
civil war so these guys
had american gis had been caught and
been brainwashed
and his job was to try and treat them
and reverse that
and he came away and wrote this book
called
thought reform of brainwashing which is
fascinating
then richard condon
i think read that book and then wrote
the manchurian candidate
which is uh was a great and successful
novel
about a brainwashed candidate for
presidency
and then um
that obviously was doing the film of
frank sinatra
then it lay um layla for a bit
and then the israelis re reversioned
that story somebody had been kidnapped
and brainwashed by hezbollah turning
into an israeli
um politician
and an israeli soldier had been
brainwashed
and then homeland came along and pinched
that story
from the israeli um drama
and reversion it again all of which
tells you that there are no new plots in
hollywood
but also that this
this is a a big thing
and um i i
so that scientology isn't just a wacky
vicious money thing
it also might help you unlock stuff
one of the things that lifton talks
about
and i believe this passionately is that
is that the authoritarian mind or the
totalitarian mind
abhors humor it has no tolerance
for mockery or a sense of humor and
therefore you've got to like and admire
and support
tolerance and mockery in our leaders
and in our own in our own doings
right right whatever and and and part of
the reason
i think as i said that mike rinder left
the scientology gang and joined the
slightly rubbish
bbc panorama gang was because we had
more fun
and my colleagues could could mock me
and nothing would happen and i
laughed along too right and that is a a
central thing anyway so mike
um is um having broken from scientology
organized a kind of
event in florida um on the gulf coast uh
where you could hit a goal
up the road from um um
scientology um what's it called saint
petersburg
around clearwater yeah yeah um up the
road from there
in a hotel and there was about a hundred
ex-members of the church of scientology
this is very early on
and uh me and my uh their misses were
split up but we
saw great friends we were invited out
and it was the most
they paid for us to go there and it felt
like
being inside galaxy quest
that there were the fans who were
ex-members of the church of scientology
and the thing is i mean i didn't do this
but had i charged five dollars
for th to do the shout you were not
there i would have cleaned up
because everybody wanted a video of me
or a picture of me going
you were not there and they kind of
treated me like
a god and i had to say listen
you've left the gods you know the crazy
gods but by the way i was brought up a
catholic i
get religious belief i understand it i'm
still
a bit of a catholic myself not very much
but a bit
so i don't want to knock other people's
religious belief i don't think
scientology is a religion i think it's a
money-making device
it's a ponzi scheme or it's like the
mafia or the coca-cola
corporation or all three
um but it's not a it's not a religion in
my book
never mind but there was something
slightly cultish
about me being the about me being
scientology's devil
but mike invited me to his wedding um
and and i and i and that really is
for mike this um
heavy duty scientologist as he was and
he was still
for a time he believed in the works of
hubbard but didn't like
the church the thing and and i think now
he's out out
but for a time anyway in the middle of
this
there am i at his bloody wedding and it
was wonderful and good
bonkers tell a quick story when i was in
trouble
real psychological trouble psychiatric
trouble with the tommy robinson attacks
and not being allowed to defend myself
by the bbc eventually i had to go sick
and i saw a psychiatrist and the
psychiatrist said
before we start mr sweeney i really
enjoyed your film about scientology
then the bbc hired a second psychiatrist
a professor of psychiatry
who was going to check my psychiatrist
who said that i've been put under
impossible work stress
and therefore they couldn't sack me in
the way they were trying to sack me
and um my the professor of psychiatry
said
mr sweeney before we start i just wanted
to say
i really liked your film about
scientology what do you want me to write
that's amazing yeah it's true um
the um it's true i said the high-pitched
voice i don't know why
i'm i'm somebody who kind of lies all
the time apart from when i go high [ __ ]
it's true
but um no that's none of those things
are true
actually some anyway never mind um
getting back to the main event
you